It's never gonna work you can't make a potato camera potatoes are meant for one thing only eating
Wren check out this picture. I just took it's one of my favorites take down how a potato or something actually I did
So there's this saying on the Internet. When you see a really bad picture you go what you take that on your potato?
Well, I want to answer that question. Yes, I did
I've never actually tried to make a camera before it sounds really complicated
But the thing is if I use film it makes my life a little bit easier
So here's the challenge take an actual potato
Carve it out so that you have a film spot inside where your film can sit and you slap a lens on the front
Can I actually make a working potato camera? Let's find out
There's a whole range of tests that we have to do here. I think at the end of the day what's probably gonna happen?
We're gonna build the camera. We're going to keep it in a bag or a box. Until it's time to take a picture
at which point we'll just take it out, expose it, put it back. Keep it quick. We also got lots of problems
We're gonna have to deal with one light if any light gets into this potato when it has film in it
It's going to ruin the film. It's gonna expose it
We need to cut one of these open and see if light can travel through a potato. I'm thinking it can yeah
That's a lot of light
How do you want to deal with this? I kind of don't want to spray paint it black
I don't think it'll adhere or dry I agree
You know what might work, build a little 3d printed chamber and just keep this in to open. Mm-hmm
How did that take a print anything probably do it quick. Let's try it
Let's do it time to do some 3d modeling combining new technology with old potatoes and PLA printers
I'm have a chamber for the film ideally to you know, be ideal to like Messing like this film backing 38 millimeters tall
yeah, so 50 millimeters wide so this
muffled screams
Test test test test test
Muffled screams
You guys ready to get
Smoked there we go. That's it. You just cover the top with gaff tape me a little big
We'll see what happens. If you do let's go smaller. Rather get smaller than too big. I don't know
Because it's like how big is it? It's like 40 40 millimeters tall film is 36 doesn't go so much play Nick
I'm a doing man. We're gonna take some
Here we go
Then we get into the mechanics of this thing where the lens is gonna sit
chop that flat and we'll kind of carve out a little bit of a hole that old lens will fit in we're gonna take the
Top of the tato and chop that like this. It's gonna lift the top off carve out a spot inside now
The thing is we need be able to roll the film through here
We'll have a film gate and then it'll go down here into a chamber or the film can go so cold around town here in
LA you think you'd be able to find a place?
I can do whatever you want for film but no films dead apparently
So the best we could find was a shop that would do nine inch strips of film
So we bought a couple 35 millimeter film Louis. We're going got to do nine inch strips at a time now
It's kind of a waste. We only do one picture per nine inch strips
So Nick and I are challenging ourselves
To make it so you do multiple exposures on one strip of film rolling the film through in the film gate
How do we know if we can fit the film in there simple how big it's known 24 by 36 mm
See, how wide the step is. Oh, it's perfect. This is like exactly the same size
Wow who thought they would have standardize tape rolls and film the same size. All right, so we need nine inches
Vegan camera imagine that there's a hole cut in this balsa wood and here's our film roll
We're gonna go in the back open it up move the film one ring for its. Theoretically this should all work out
Eh, okay. Look at that some focus
Yeah
Yeah, the little proof of concept build seems to be working when aiwei's? a real test to do here
Going good to be back. Finally. It's been too long went through my second year in college in San Francisco
Whose great year got to live with my best friends. Lots of Adventure is great times, but I also
Shot my very own spider-man short film which I will now be editing
Here, which is pretty exciting. So basically I've been wanting to make a spider-man movie for as long as I can
Remember, I grew up watching the Sam Raimi spider-man movies. Probably my biggest inspirations so good. Don't watch the spider-man 3
One of my pet peeves is just bring that movie. I hate that movie so much. It's definitely its own movie
I wrote a script for a spider-man short last year and I've been working on getting it made thankfully
I had put together a teaser that is already on my Instagram showed that to Jake had some of the effects in it he was
Impressed he showed it to Sam and Nico they were into it
And so they gave me the budget to make this short film all on my own in San Francisco
There were two big challenges with this project one. It's a period piece
it's set in the 1960s which for a short film is very difficult because
Costuming takes a lot of money, you know, it's really hard to get that many extras to fill a background to make you know
the space feel realistic part of how we're going to fix that is through lots and lots of visual effects like
So many the other challenge was putting spider-man in a movie because obviously that comes with a lot of challenges
You know acrobatics the costume took many many hours to create made it from scratch
Couldn't get a stunt double. So thankfully we have visual effects right now
I'm working on creating Spiderman from the ground up and CGI a lot of its gonna be hand animating
Which is really tough mostly the swinging sequences because you can't really film someone
swinging in between buildings to like see how their movements look
Hopefully I can finish this before the end of June which is when it's due. So, I guess we'll see
Yeah, it's gonna be tough. I'm gonna be working. Some late hours. Probably definitely lots of pressure. Lots of big shoes to fill right?
It's not gonna help me with baby wanna help my mom man, you're spider-man 3 pin
It's pretty good there the windows just fine - time to carve out master potato and
Ideas, this is where a film will go a lot of being better. Dang. Look at that. Great
Do you think this will be able to compete with the red maybe only in terms of
Style like the Reds all black with like cool skulls and this is all like yellow with like cool
smells
Hey you think this is just an ordinary potato think again
Kato camera. All right. So I finished hollowing out the potato this fits in there nice and snug and that's gonna protect an image
Hopefully into our film. All right, so the potato construction is done
We're ready to throw the film chamber in there take our pictures, but I want to make sure this lens is working
We're gonna put this on a real camera. We're gonna get a sense of exposure
What settings should we be at because we need to have to stop down a fair amount
well
We're sure we can do is we can control the aperture of this lens and the tighter the aperture the more things are in focus
We can't see or shooting you can only point the potato at it and hope it comes out beautifully so set the aperture to around
F11 and then we know our film is 100
Iso so we put this lens on real camera when we stop it down to 11 and we set the cameras ISO to 100
Then we should get a reading for the shutter speed how long we need to take our lens cap off and then put it back
On to take our picture here at 1/4 of a second. It's a perfect exposure in here
It's a potato camera
I think this is gonna work
I have a Raider load some film in this son of a look at my new camera is where I think it does
So we'll have the lens cap on it's time to take a picture and just take it off and put it back on
Blurry we have these a tripod
Think having a Toledo
Existence there's more of a priority than whether or not is blurry man. That reason just there is doubt in my potato camera
It's never gonna work ever you can't make a potato camera. You know what you should give up now
Potatoes are meant for one thing. Only eating is gonna get popular and there's gonna be another famine. Ah isn't there
so we have one more big challenge ahead of us for to get this to work thing is if any light hits the
Undeveloped film it ruins it straight up. So we need to be in a pitch-black room
Let me cut the film into nine inch strips
We need to stay in that pitch-black room when you load it into here and make sure it's love it correctly
We get it all sealed up. We can't let any light leak into this potato if that happens
The film is ruined traditionally in dark rooms. They have a light with a red of a certain wavelength. It doesn't expose the film
I thought I'd feel ups you light might work, but we decided not to risk it. We're gonna go extra safe
I'm going to use an infrared camera and be in pitch blackness for this to work. Okay?
Just gotta memorize everything is
You get plates everything beforehand. Here we go
I can't see anything. There's some low in the dark things on the ceiling apparently, dude
Should we turn on the light to take this bit better?
That's not good to breathe
I Recently retired from corridor digital and moved to Fiji because this episode is brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is so easy to use that. I just quit and move to a faraway Island
It's so easy. I make websites for everybody here in Fiji Squarespace has beautiful award-winning templates
Meaning you don't need to know anything about color in order to use their website. Do you see that?
Do you see those surfers down there?
Hey guys
Yeah
They're having a great time because you know why Squarespace is flexible for any kind of website
Meaning that if you're a surfer a Frank over there
Hey, I see you crazy animal don't think you're going anywhere
Squarespace has an all-in-one platform. Meaning there's nothing to install patch or upgrade ever
Do you feel that ocean breeze
That's what they're 24/7 award-winning customer service feels like so great
Remember you can get $10 off your first purchase by going to squirt space.com forward slash corridor crew right now. You'll thank me. Later
cannonball
Now make sure we don't over expose the film go down
But Spencer died in a train accident 20 years ago
Kill those lights
All right ready seal, okay, I'm gonna turn on the light go for it. Let's do it. Yeah, don't move
Okay, that's it now, I did one I need to advance the film so I need to open this up again and do that
If we get any image if you can even make out a human I'll be happy that would be successful
If there's any actual yeah, even if it's blurry, even though we've been really careful. There's probably a 30% chance
We're actually gonna get something 30% chance, but something will actually get anything. Yeah
These black squares are the exposures. Oh man. There's a ghost to them see people
Like these ghostly people something lorries happen right there. It only works totally
Holy $&!% when they developed it, they didn't think it worked. Okay. There's a Slenderman That's a really good Slendy right there we have all the negatives here
So now we need to do is scan them in and inverse the colors so you can see what the images look like
Nice gate. It's probably super blurry and out of focus
Probably oh my god that totally worked
There's actually people
I'm not sure who that was. I think that's you. Yeah, I think this is Gabe. I'm believe gaben Peter. I think yeah
Yeah
I think there might even double imprints like here this photo might have been in one of these
When I was laying on top of it something we did like double expose which is kind of cool actually
Yeah, you can actually see the logo the indigo print slow going game yeah
That's Jake and Christian. I am their arms fricking boss mode dude. Definitely out of focus
Yeah!
Believe I can see you're right. Yeah, I can see. Yeah, I can see it here
Well, you can see the light switch. You can see the door to the conduit box. This is a really spooky woman
That's like zone that looks like album art or a dark. Ambient
So that's you Clint. And that's
Yeah, oh yeah
Oh, who is this Oh, who's this someone with a gun? No this with an axe or holy intern scanner. That's Christian
Yeah doing is I'm classic Christian pose that work virtually. Well, it's in focus. Actually. This makes me
Feel like foggy if you stand back and blurrier eyes, you can see his camo shorts. Yep
You see white shoes white socks and his arms conflict. Yeah, that's really good. Oh wow
I'm super in focus freakin Slenderman over here, dude. Hey, who's this?
That's definitely me a manly just cuz I remember specifically doing that pose that cheek. Yeah, that's Jake. Definitely Jay
Let's definitely Jake these ones. Actually these ones are almost perfect
To be honest with you exposure wise like kind of about as good as it gets
So potato camera does exactly what we thought it would do which is take crappy
But still visible pictures kind of work like we got these weird ghostly figures which is actually exactly what I was hoping for